foreign
[Music]
thank you
let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads explode let me be clear
before this podcast begins we are loud
loud
and do not give a [__]
this is the Tony Michaels podcast real
and raw political and social commentary
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not Liberty you [__]
eating [__] ah the smell of freedom of
speech this is the Tony Michaels podcast
and this is Tony Michaels
hey Tony [__] them
[Music]
foreign
everyone how are you guys doing today
it is Tuesday you know what that means
tacos tacos tacos also Texas Paul
uh we're finding out that Tony is still
missing
don't know could be in the Lake of the
Ozarks could be sleeping in bed I don't
know the guy needs some rest so we're
gonna we're gonna take over for him one
more day the inmates are running the
asylum
again the inmates are running the asylum
we're gonna see what's going on today
all right so the first
the first news story that I really want
to dive in today uh and we'll talk more
with Texas Paul I'm sure he's got some
stuff to say about everything that's
going on but uh My Boy George Santos
uh Anthony to Boulder George Anthony
devolder Santos guitar ravage uh you
know he goes by many names
he's got questionably two faces
um but uh but I don't know if anyone saw
recently but George Santos decided that
when it came to
uh when it came to giving up the names
of the three people who put in the 500
or you know uh uh
became responsible as the bond
guarantors
uh for the 500 000 Bail Bond
it sounds like
he doesn't want to [__] give up the
names because it might be because
snitches
get snitches uh
but so George Santos uh he according to
his lawyer George Santos said that he
would rather go to jail
and give up the names of the three
people that put the five hundred
thousand dollar bail bond behind his
name after he was indicted for 13 felony
criminal counts I don't know if you guys
remember that was about a three weeks
about a month ago
so yeah it sounds like and look sounds
fine to me honestly the guy wants to go
to jail
instead of giving up the three names
that's fine if he wants to do that hey
bet go for it do it my friend
if that's what you really want you'd
rather go to jail than actually put up
the names because
I don't know maybe the names are
connected to Miles guo the one who's
connected to Steve Bannon uh he's very
on that anti-ccp the China route
um
it could also be connected to someone in
Russia right we know that he has
relatives in Russia as well right if you
look at where the money came from a lot
of questions come up in terms of where
his individual Revenue was coming from
right you know I see some people saying
collusion right go to jail such a drama
queen I mean Georgie Georgie Georgie
not a smart move I mean if I'm being
honest it's not a not a smart move but
hey I mean if the people that are
pulling the strings behind George Santos
are that
afraid are that scared are that much of
a snowflake
that George Santos has to honestly take
the fall for them yeah okay I mean we'll
eventually find out who it is I don't I
don't see that any precedence I don't
see any [__]
um
actual excuse for why this should be
allowed I I'm almost gonna guarantee
that the magistrate who's overseeing
this case
uh is going to
just say look
we're not going to protect these names
anymore so he's he's supposed to be uh
coming back to coming back to court on
June 30th uh let me just make sure real
quick but the fact that George Santos
again is willing to protect these three
people
um is is quite interesting honestly if
you think about it right um here let me
pull this up
so everyone can read along with me
so as you can see here it says lawyer
says representative George Santos would
go to jail to keep identities of bond
cosigners secret so I just want to give
context for anyone who's jumping in
right now and wondering exactly why
we're talking about George Santos
because he's kind of been out of the
spotlight for the last few weeks right
um the last time was when he showed up
to the courthouse and then there was one
more time which is actually what this
photo is from is when he was on uh the
capital steps and that's when the Tiff
between uh Jamal Bowman and marger
Taylor green happened and then Margaret
Taylor green tried to you know play I'm
the victim and he was very very mean to
me uh despite there being literal video
footage right
so I just want to give context to uh
to to this photo right here which is
George Santos on the steps now as I said
the lawyer says representative George
Santos would rather go to jail to keep
the identity of the bond cosigner Secret
and in here it says on Monday so he had
an extent he had a deadline that was
Friday and he was given an extension
until Monday at 5 pm and the extension
was this moment right here so he said
representative George Sanders his lawyer
said Monday that the end uh the indicted
New York Republican would risk going to
jail to protect the identities of the
people who co-signed the 500 000 Bond
enabling his pre-trial release
and the reason why it says the lawyer
Joseph Murray urged a judge to deny a
request by news outlets because there
was a medley of news outlets like the
New York Times and Washington Post and
other people who had filed to say like
this isn't normal these names can't be
protected nor should they be protected
there's no merit there's no precedent
for why this would happen for any normal
representative
so uh it says the to unseal the names of
Santa's shirters or guarantors
suggesting they could suffer great
distress including possible job losses
and physical harm if they're identified
publicly
uh I I have to disagree wholeheartedly
if someone's going to willingly state
that they'll put up because they didn't
have to put up 500 000 they put up I
think 10 percent
uh but still it's five hundred thousand
dollars on the line if George Santos for
whatever reason doesn't show up he's if
he leaves he's no longer found whatever
it might be they're on the hook for five
hundred thousand dollars
and it says my client would rather
surrender to pre-trial detainment than
subject these surgers to what will
inevitably come right
and he wrote this to the U.S Magistrate
Judge Ann Shields
and he's due back
in court on June 30th so he's got what's
today June 6th so he's got 20 24 days
until he's got a show back up right but
um
this is one of those things oh and in
The Last Detail I'll say here is uh
Murray said Santos originally lined up
three financially responsible
responsible co-signers as suraters but
one backed out and the other two didn't
show up to the arraignment
hmm
how suspicious very suspicious
that's very weird
and that forced them to make other
confidential arrangements to ensure
Santa's release so according to him they
had three financially responsible
co-signers and then all of a sudden
uh they were like oh they didn't show up
so we had to find three people to come
off the bench as a substitute
I don't know about you but that sounds
real [__] suspicious okay the fact
that
you have to come up with an excuse to be
like oh we had someone we had someone we
we totally had people that were totally
willing to identify themselves to the
public however
however they didn't show up so then we
had to find these other arrangements
right
um
very sus it's it's one of those things
where it's run-of-the-mill very very
expected we'll say right you look at
George Santos he's a republican every
Republican will find a way to cheat
steal kill or con people out of uh
actually being responsible holding
responsibility and having accountability
for the crime that did right
and George Santos whether it's hubris or
whatever I mean it's quite quite
impressive to watch this Republican
Party
You know despite the fact that there are
Republicans trying to distance
themselves somewhat from George Santos
right this guy is in it to win it I mean
he's really taking the trumpism
mentality uh
to the Finish Line right
and I wouldn't be surprised if the
identities were revealed because again
like I said there's no [__] precedent
there's no reason why you would need to
protect the names of these people right
um there I could only imagine that if
you're putting yourself on the line for
five hundred thousand dollars between
three people you know the idea that
you're going to say well we're concerned
for the financial
repercussions the financial
consequences that might come from their
identities being revealed right I have a
very hard time
seeing that as a possibility
I do not see the people
these these Anonymous suspicious
uh [__]
um guarantors these these people who
have put their names and and their
status behind the bonds right I don't
see that
as something that would actually Merit
protection
because
there is no good reason
to actually have that and keep in mind
right they had the whole time
until Friday
to
to answer this request right and then it
came up till Friday almost up to the
deadline and they said no no we [__]
need till Monday
we need till Monday
and everyone's like why do you need an
extra two days right or I guess three
days until the end of end of Monday
like it feels like you had this whole
you had a month you had a month
to figure this out you could not come up
with a valid excuse or you could not put
in a petition
before then
right
and you have to look at the situation
and I mean despite the fact that George
Santos has been able to get away with
what he's been able to get away with
right
It's a combination of of hubris
[__] stupidity and incompetence
and and it really is luck right it's
that three kind of Trifecta that
combination you know you see the
connection Steve Bannon Matt Gates miles
guo I'm willing to defend miles guo who
if you just Google miles guo you'll read
the medley
of of of crimes and the reason that the
doj took them
right and then you know there's photos
of of miles guo on the on the yacht with
Steve Bannon right
there's there's no coincidence in this
world of politics especially for the
Republican Party they're all connected
they're all doing something they're all
jerking each other off they're all you
know
doing favors for each other
and you look
at what
the party represents
and you see that it's just a lot of that
it's a lot of George Santos right
it's a lot who's who's the the
representative I think representative
from Tennessee
um I'm blanking on his name let me just
look this up there's a representative of
Tennessee
Andy ogles right Andy ogles another gun
groping uh
uh Mega right uh and just to give people
contacts I'll pull up a photo discuss
who you guys remember Andy ogles is the
guy that you know also had some Choice
words after the Nashville shooting
uh a person that despite the fact that
he's representing the state of Tennessee
and there was a school a mass school
shooting
the the apathy that these people have
um
you know like I said another person
who's taking Family Photos groping guns
and and this is
this is what I'm talking about
right here
again this is Thomas Massey Lauren
bobert
this is all of them they all do this
Marjorie Taylor green they're all these
Fanatics these crazy Mega nut jobs
that are so [__] invested
in their own own
personal
uh advancement right selfishness again I
said yesterday we saw you know that we
see this all the time the selfishness
the the lack of empathy towards others
for caring about another person's life
their well-being
their future livelihood
they just care about themselves George
Santos again is a perfect example of
this the guy will never show up to his
district the only time he ever shows up
to New York or Long Island
was on two occasions one of which was to
show up to
Donald Trump's arraignment
in Manhattan
the second one was to show up to the
courthouse for his own arraignment
the only time this guy has ever shown
his face in New York City since taking
office
has been to show up for a court
arraignment
again only shows up when a crime is
involved and and they have to show their
face
but any other time these Republicans
will never show their face
they will run Dodge avoid anyone
possible that they can
they don't [__] care about anyone
we saw that in the debt limit deal
and we'll talk about that with Texas
Paul and there's more that we got to
talk about too and we talked about
yesterday with Dr Rachel bidikoffer but
the Republican party doesn't care right
they would rather cut Social Security
cut Medicare
cut these programs
because of their own selfishness their
greed
their incompetence
right but every time we see it done
we need to call it out
you know Lauren bobert again running up
the stairs like Rocky Balboa trying to
put the vote in
and then trying to change the narrative
to say oh no no no revisionist
revisionist time revisionist time I I
objected to the vote and we'll we'll
play that video today with Texas ball as
well
I objected to the vote everyone no no I
stood my ground I stood my ground and I
said no Kevin McCarthy I will not
support this vote
and then CNN's like actually we have the
footage of her literally running up the
steps getting caught Midway saying the
vote's over she says the vote's over and
then continues to run up the steps right
there's always a receipt there's always
a tweet there's always a photo there's
always a video there's always some
literal receipt of purchase of something
they did
to prove
the opposite of what they said or what
they did right and I guarantee this same
thing will be done with George Santos
well find out the identities of these
three guarantors right we'll find out
the identity of who these people are
whether it's miles guo someone connected
to Bannon
the mob Russia who knows right I'm sure
it will not be a disappointing thing and
when we find out we'll be like yeah
we [__] saw that coming we expected
it right because not only is it George
Santos but it's the Republican Party
these people
do not care
they are they are only in it for
themselves
they only care about themselves
I mean it's you know I see people in the
chat it's got to be Russia Russia Russia
you know I see people saying it's the
mob honestly it could be any one of
those things
and and I wouldn't be surprised it's not
like it's I mean who knows it could be
George Santos's mom maybe she put in the
money right I don't know if she's
actually gone or not George Santo said
that she passed away on two different
occasions she could be still alive who
knows right who knows and honestly I
wouldn't put it past him
to say that
she was still around or rather that her
name was on the [__] dotted line to
ever sign for it
it's it is it is something else
but
it's not to be I mean it is totally to
be expected right
it is something that we see again and
again
and
and as we look at all of these things
happening right every day you know you
might you might and I do want to I do
want to kind of end this on a on a
positive note uh but you see these
people
do these crimes right and you think ah
they're getting away with it right
they're getting away with it
but Justice is coming right it might be
slow
but it's coming right we saw there's
video that we'll show today of of Jack
Smith walking you know MSNBC asking them
hey Jack Smith you want to give a
comment [__] Stone Cold face does not
want to talk nor should he
right
the guy eats [__] nails for breakfast
okay a bowl of nails doesn't
emote anything and you'll see it in this
video straight face they even said in
this interview from uh
in in MSNBC they're like we don't know
where the [__] this guy is like we have
not been able to track him down he's
somewhere in DC but we know he's not at
the [__] doj
he's in a safe house somewhere he's got
a team Nobody Knows the location it's a
secret for obvious reasons
I mean you see what we're we're hearing
from from the Trump Camp right he's
freaking out there's been developments
of this mysterious flood that happened
in Mar-A-Lago next to where the
computers were and the servers were it's
all very suspicious
but like I said
do not lose Faith
Justice is [__] coming for these
people
and the first one on the docket
other than George Santos
is Donald Trump
the first one
on the docket other than George Santos
is Donald Trump he's freaking out over
Fulton County he's freaking out over
Mar-A-Lago
he's getting scared
and now that we hear these things coming
out more and more about the case with
the mar logo Mar-A-Lago classified
documents
we're learning
that this is way more of a [__] show
than we could imagine right the
maintenance worker saying that he was
part of the group that moved it right
we had the the Evan Corcoran oh don't go
into the Donald Trump's office because
there's documents over there
you find out that there's a recording of
Donald Trump saying oh oh duh I
acknowledge that I took these documents
without permission and I knew I should
not have done that
then you find out that there are
documents that are still missing
and Trump's legal team are like we don't
know where they are
and then another [__] shoe drops
we find out yesterday from a CNN
exclusive
that there was a flood at the Mar-A-Lago
pool
that they had to clean up now to what
extent the damage was with what was in
the rooms that were affected yet to be
determined
but it just goes to show you that this
this group of people the Republican
Party Donald Trump are [__] sus as
hell
if you thought it was [__] suss
before
just the stuff from last week and this
week we're only Tuesday Monday they
dropped the story
I guarantee you if this is how Monday
starts we're gonna find out more we know
that the grand jury is reconvening Jack
Smith is in DC walking around out in
public first time that we've ever seen
this guy in public other than the photos
that we've seen that people share around
which is straight faced and from the
side
Stern no emotion
and now we see him walking around in DC
because he's getting ready he's showing
up he's about to drop the hammer
and we're going to talk more about this
with Texas Paul
so we're gonna go to Commercial and
we're gonna come right back and we're
gonna get his thoughts
all right
what the [__] is wrong with you people
it's a rhetorical question at best
we'll be right back on the Tony Michaels
podcast
[Music]
fellow Patriots what would you do if
there was a trump supporter right in
front of you crying in pain because they
have to live under communist tyranny we
know what you would do you'd reach out
and give that true American a hand now
here's your chance for only fifty
dollars a day you can help us help those
true Americans recover from Biden's
socialist reign of terror these are
those Trump supporters and this is that
moment send your donation via venmo to
the real president Donald J Trump it's
only fifty dollars a day recurring and
it means you'll get these Trump
supporters the critical help they so
desperately need to survive under this
false regime please donate now because
those Trump supporters you just saw
can't wait another moment where
back to the Tony Michaels podcast
it's Tuesday you know what that means
Taco Tuesday with Texas fall
like I said the inmates are running the
Asylum today
me
in Texas Paul
how you doing man let's make Tony regret
this [__]
he's uh I think he's recovering he was
out yesterday he got a lot of sun it
looked like you know I mean much much
deserved much needed vacation for the
guy but it looks like uh
it looks like he he had a good time you
know okay you know I mean a lot of
people underestimate this because you us
clear people it is really really a big
deal when you get way too much sunburn
you can get sun sickness yeah I mean it
really I mean it it will mess you up for
days brother let me tell you I went
tubing down on the Guadalupe River one
time first set of waterfalls we went
over my cooler flipped over lost half my
beer all my sunscreen my shirt because I
had my shirt off for the first few
minutes right I mean only takes me about
20 minutes to sunburn but you know lost
my shirt because the river was moving
pretty good that day you know and just
everything I've spent two and a half
hours on a damn River floating back down
to my right I man I was
just blistered and all kinds of I was in
bed for like a week man I mean I feel
for Tony I feel for Tony that that's
yeah sun sickness is hell man yeah it
looked a little Rosy I'll see maybe
later uh we'll pull up a photo of Tony
out out as a lobster uh but uh
but oh man I mean uh let's let's talk
about let's talk about this Mar-A-Lago
pool situation because that's the big I
feel like that's the kind of big time
that's the big news that dropped
yesterday right I'll see if I can pull
that video again but I'll let you go
yeah it is the biggest load of [__]
I've ever heard in my life okay let me
tell you they're trying to say that
their server was on the ground Gabe come
on man come on man I mean if it was in a
server rack one it would no way it was
on the ground if it was even in a in a
whatever even a mid Tower you know if
they were running their server out of a
mid Tower the only thing that could have
got flooded was the power supply you and
I both know that the drives are at the
top of the damn Tower I mean it's
there's no damn way that this is
legitimate just technologically
physically not possible there there is a
part of me where I'm like
um I get um
like I know I know how you know the
setup and the structure is of uh if
you're if you're having a local server
right and how you should maintain it I
mean I don't know what the room
conditions were right of how they had it
but I also wouldn't be surprised if they
were that dumb to say yeah I'll put on
the ground right like there is that
slight possibility that you could look
at whoever was in charge of their I.T
department and said yeah you know what
the ground is the coolest place so we'll
put it there but to your point I I
wholeheartedly agree it's very
suspicious right and and again trying to
figure out I got the video here
um
trying to figure out exactly the timing
I don't know if we've we've learned when
this was or when it happened but we just
learned about it yesterday
um so it's four days ago or something
like that it was when they first started
to talk about it and then yeah it went
viral yesterday right right it was
restored that's according to sources
this comes to CNN we're in special
counsel Jack Smith attended a meeting
today with Trump's lawyers here in
Washington D.C at the Department of
Justice CNN's Evan Perez is with me Evan
what do we know about this pool incident
it seems a little fishy well I think
that's one of the things that
prosecutors have been focusing on Jake
they have been asking Witnesses about
this incident that happened in October
uh sources telling uh Caitlyn Collins
and Caitlyn polands that there was an
employee there at Mara Lago who
apparently drained the pool and the pool
and it caused a flooding inside a room
where there's a server that holds some
of the surveillance uh equipment and so
yeah also super convenient that it was
just this one server that held the
surveillance and and I I would I would
go out on a limb
to assume that the
the footage that they're talking about
is the same footage that Eric Trump went
out and boasted about after the the
search happened by the FBI he went on
Sean Hannity and other places and they
talked about how they had footage that
would reveal and expose the FBI for the
crooks that they are and show that how
they're super corrupt right and I'll see
if I can find that clip because Sean
Hannity in that interview is like okay
so you have the footage right and it
goes yeah yeah we we have the footage
and he's like okay are you going to
release that footage to kind of uh
show that show that Trump is the victim
here and he's like oh well and then
skirted around it you know and what his
answer was
well let's not entertain this like this
is actually something that we could you
know because it's not I mean take a look
at Mar-A-Lago you know you just showed
the clip of mar-locker it is a round
structure surrounding the pool and then
the entire half hemisphere of that is
grass that runs downhill right you're
going to pump out that pool
you're going to do it in the grass
period you're not going to run you're
not going to drain it out onto the
sidewalk where the rooms are and all
that other that's not going to happen so
that is just utter [__] okay the
second thing that you've got to say is
complete [__] is unless they were
running external hard drives and decided
hey you know what
the dirty floor is the perfect
environment for a hard drive let me put
my hard drive on the floor no this did
not happen this just did not happen
anybody that knows anything about any of
this said heard this and said
[__]
just straight out it is it just it just
is there's no way to entertain this
yeah there there are moments or I mean
there are just like key parts of this
where you look at it and you're like
this doesn't
it doesn't add up right it's one more
thing
to show how
they're trying to put up blockades along
the way oh well we didn't have this oh
no we said we had this oh well we you
know uh we
we promised that we did it when we
signed this affidavit we promised that
we did this right and I actually have
the uh I actually have the interview of
Sean Hannity with Eric Trump where he's
talking about this
um but again it's every step along the
way and I kind of talked about this
yesterday on the show which is like
you have Donald Trump and his team
saying they don't have any documents
there was never any documents to begin
with then they said well the documents
because the documents were planted right
it's a hoax it's a Witch Hunt the FBI
put them there to which then Trump said
oh no no no no actually actually uh
uh we did take them but it's because
they're my documents I was the president
when I had the documents despite the
fact that they weren't supposed to leave
the skiff and we took photos and we
brought them uh to Mar-A-Lago and then I
Declassified them in the Oval Office
with cash Patel and and then you know
and it's just one excuse after another
and Maga will wholeheartedly believe it
you've got all of the GOP saying
oh yeah I mean I guess that makes sense
honestly we're so bought in now we can't
we can't tell the difference between
truth and a lie because whatever Trump
says is what we have to believe and so
every time
every time they they just continue to
dig that ditch right they just got the
show
you brought up a great point there about
Trump saying these documents were mine
this that and the other you gotta when
they strip you of your
your clearance they tell you I mean they
they come to you and say hey
can we talk for a minute oh by the way
you no longer have clearance don't
access anything don't look at anything
you no longer have clearance and Donald
Trump was one of the only presidents and
that I can think of that actually had
their security clearance taken away when
he left office now let's say for just a
second that he you know is too into his
freaking Big Macs and all his other
[__] and this that and the other and
he just didn't listen to the guy that
showed up and said hey
I'm taking your clearance away I need
everything out of your office that you
know let's say he didn't he was I don't
know freaking high or something when
that happened
this guy watches television 24 freaking
seven yeah yeah I mean if he's awake
he's watching television I mean he gets
his views from TV
yeah I mean that that was a big news
story there is no way he believed one
that he was entitled to these documents
and two that he had any authority to
even look at them anymore right
I mean it it's all [__] like you
said each layer every iteration of this
story is just more and more [__]
well we don't have documents well yeah
you do we know you do well you know what
I you know I don't have the documents
you're looking for I didn't take those
are oh well we found them there okay we
came out we actually found them there we
know you had them there's more documents
missing oh well I don't know where those
documents are this that need a Corcoran
leave the room leave the room Corcoran
leave the room you don't want to know
about this you know I mean it's just
been every iteration has been [__]
and now you know this last one about the
flooding if they took buckets of water
let's say I mean what tower do you think
they would run their server out of
I mean if it was a Dell server it was a
desktop I mean but you know for
something that's Molly was it you know
you've seen the desktop console yeah
they're all I mean the other thing too
is like you never like depending on
where you have it I mean I would of
course if I were to set this up in
anywhere it would be someone that was
away rooms away from anywhere where they
were gallons of water right I don't know
how much is an Olympic-sized pool but
you would never say oh you know what I
should put this very important
electronic device that holds this very
important data on it near where the
possibility of a flood could happen
right but again
yeah I know you know this you know this
you know that if they took buckets of
water and poured them over that Tower
and folks when I say a tower when you
talk about a desktop computer there's a
mini tower there's a mid Tower there's a
ATX now I mean there's a real big one
that I love which you know can hold like
16 fans and you know that's typically
what you want to run a server out of if
you took buckets of water and you poured
it over that you would short your power
supply you would short your motherboard
but you know what you know what wouldn't
be [__] up pardon my language
no it wouldn't be
your hard drive because you either have
and I know Donald Trump didn't pay for
solid state drives I mean that cheap SOB
didn't he had the old-fashioned
whirlybird you know he did not pay for
ssds he did not right but even if he did
if you poured gallons I mean it went
down to Home Depot got you Homer buckets
and filled them with water and just
soaked that damn thing
you could still take those drives hand
them over to the FBI they would very
deftly and quickly crack them open they
would pull the disc out put it into a
new drive and it would still be
completely magnetized they would still
be able to pull the data off of it yeah
you intentionally
ran a loop over your hard drive you know
what a loop it is it's demagnetizing
Loop you intentionally ran a loop over
your hard drive
and that's and they'll know because you
know Gabe you know damn well what I'm
saying this definitely there are
everything in it yeah when you run a
loop over so everything is lost you know
I mean it's it's it's really obvious
you'll have you'll have uh for people
who don't know like if you're trying to
frag uh a hard drive or you know
basically you take a magnet and you drag
it across there are going to be key
signatures and and this is just from
someone who knows like basic hard drive
like repair and Recovery right but if
you've got people here like hey you're
the best in the field when it comes to
being a technician for repairing hard
drives right or or recovering data
you know you would say
uh I know exactly what was done on this
right I know exactly how like what
method they used you know how powerful
or whatever you know I know exactly the
damage I can text I can test for
moisture right I can also test to see
what other
uh malicious activity was done against
this this hard drive and you have
there's no way because I can almost I
can also guarantee that once they it's
like ah you know it's like when um
you know I guess like when you're in
school and you're trying to come up with
an excuse and you're like oh well I did
blah blah and it was like this series of
unfortunate events and that was the
reason why I couldn't turn in my
assignment and they're like I find a
very big plot hole in that excuse right
in that story and to to put a even
bigger hole in that is because so here's
here's the video I was talking about
Sean Hannity and uh and Eric Trump this
is him right after it was August 15th
and remember that the raid or the the
sorry the the FBI search happened
August 8th I believe is what it was so
this is about a week after the fact and
they're trying they're still still
struggling to get the narrative what
happened is it plans they're still
saying is this where they're still
saying we don't have documents or was
this after they acknowledge they did
have documents where in the LIE are we
here again I don't think that's a good
question I'm trying to figure out where
exactly in the lie in the timeline of
lies right the the time lies we'll call
it right uh of where we are but in this
moment which is about a week after
so this is after Trump said we have to
bring the temperature down which was you
know kind of his little dog whistle to
be like if you guys don't [__] get
off my back then I'm gonna [__] tell
my people to go after you right same
type of stuff that was Jan six uh and
luckily nothing bad happened there was
that one guy who went to the FBI with
the [__] nail gun that was just weird
uh which is like you think you're gonna
take down a local FBI
uh [__] FBI office in Ohio with a
nail gun like come on man they don't
have the documents
but here is here is Eric Trump uh in a
in a less than 30 second clip talking to
Sean Hannity about this footage
oh Sean from the mid
absolutely Sean at the right time and
your body cam point was spot on that's
why cops wear body cams they don't tell
you to turn off cameras they want
transparency and that's not what
happened here surprising this timing is
not surprising and it's backfiring on
these people will you you still have the
surveillance tape is that correct will
you are you allowed to share that with
the country
foreign
I don't know if that was was that was
that like glitchy for you yeah the audio
was off safe I got the point Yeah Yeah
so basically in this interview and uh if
I can find another one I'll find it but
basically in this interview Sean Hannity
says hey you guys have this footage
right you guys you guys have proof that
what you're telling us that Trump is the
victim and that this is all a plant and
the FBI came there and they raided it
Mar-A-Lago and no one had any idea and
no one was coordinated with uh with
Alina Hava or with uh Christina Bob or
anyone there right Christina Bob by the
way who was there and oversaw what she
could and then later was like no I
wasn't uh I wasn't the custodian of
Records I wasn't involved at all right
she had a she then went immediately back
to rsbn and started covering all the
Trump rallies because again another
incompetent lawyer in this group of
Misfits
and you know she got a phone call from
like a friend that was a lawyer saying
Alina this is a felony you don't want to
be what dude you're in danger girl like
the idea that somebody would have like
like her mom or someone was like hey
look I don't know how you like you might
want to zoom out and look at a macro
level because micro you might be too
focused right now it's not good you want
to distance yourself as much as possible
because the position you've put yourself
in by backing this guy and backing this
narrative in the event that it actually
is not what you guys are claiming it is
it's gonna be very bad right and every
person who has been a lawyer for Trump I
you know they're still loosely
associated Alina Haba still makes
appearances she was on the EJ and Carol
case then she wasn't on the E Gene
Carroll case she was on the Marlon with
documents in some fashion she wasn't
there there was you know Evan Corcoran I
don't know where he is you've got Jim
trusty he's still around he showed up
yesterday for the two-hour meeting with
the doj so like there were two other
lawyers also in the photos of the three
lawyers I was like I don't even I don't
know if I've ever seen these people
before right like the fact that there
are people who are still willing
despite you know his history of not
[__] pain people or not giving them
the time of day or or or trying to con
them right these people these lawyers
you would think that hey you know they
passed the bar there's some intelligence
like level there they go you know what
I should go work for Donald Trump
despite me knowing all these things
despite me knowing that the guy doesn't
pay or whatever it might be
I'm still gonna go work for him like
that's the level of intelligence that
he's working with on his his legal team
it's the ego though man if you've ever
dealt with these attorneys they think
that they are the Ubermensch man they
think there's no way this guy will stiff
me you know it's like Ty Cobb just the
other day you saw you saw that probably
break all over the place that that
Donald Trump
and he said he's just mad at me because
I didn't pay him yeah Ty Cobb went into
that deal thinking
they know way that guy stiffs me I mean
yeah he he needs me to save his ass and
then you know it's just a load of crap
everybody it's like Rick Wilson said
you know you know me I don't like
Republicans I don't get along with the
pro Republicans but you showed me a good
reformed Republican like Rick Wilson I
may okay with that and what he said I
bought the man's book everything Trump
touches dies
that is a great book I'm telling you Ed
and every one of these lawyers are
finding that out I mean you're 100 spot
on Gabe every one of these lawyers that
you would think would be smart enough
except for Elena I don't I don't
that that what that that had to be a
I don't know I don't hate to be crude
but he picked her for looks that was it
oh I mean I mean there's this there's
definitely there's definitely the photo
of them in the in the Jet right they
were they were going to some rally and
she's there in her white suit and he's
standing right and
it looks her hand yeah it's like where's
her hand what's going on right hand
checked and you have this moment where
it looks very similar to a photo of him
with Melania it looks very similar to a
photo with him in Ivanka right it's very
kind of like we know how much of a creep
the guy is we know that he has clearly
obviously had affairs he has been uh he
has sexually assaulted women rape women
he has done these things so it wouldn't
be outside the norm of him to cheat or
do any of these things and have these
women who felt like they might not be or
might not have power in any position
right
so like the idea that you see a photo
like that Alina have and you're like oh
for looks oh 100 there is no reason why
I think Elena habit would be anything
more than that I mean you look at the
fact that Elena Haba is has been found I
mean she was sued by a former employee
for being racist right creating a racist
workplace so that's the type of people
that Donald Trump is obviously working
with it you know unsurprising for sure
but also it's one of those things where
it's like oh yeah I
she is not there for any intelligence at
all yeah yeah and and
to the the shock that that that people
have When Ty Cobb comes out and totally
trashes Donald Trump and then Donald
Trump's biggest defense is he's just mad
because I never paid my bill
come on man but he doesn't right like
that's the guy he does not pay the bill
you look you look at Rudy Giuliani there
was that I think it was like 2021 there
was that quote he gave and he said he
was joking but it's like I don't know
how much you were actually joking where
the thing was like how much do you owe
and he's like oh well you know Donald
Trump is being billed I think twenty
thousand dollars a month or whatever for
my legal you know kind of counsel and
then uh they were like oh so he's gonna
pay it and he's like well if he doesn't
I've got insurance wink wink right and
you're like
so we
are you gonna use that like what's going
on like you clearly know he's not paying
anyone and you're not getting paid so
what are you gonna do about it right
and you know there are attorneys out
there
um do you know the the Ken Paxton I
don't want to get off on a side thing
here just just talking about the
attorneys yeah Ken Paxton is being
impeached the house here in Texas
wisely hired dick degarin and a guy by
the name of Randy Hardin
and I I'm pardon me Rusty Hardin and I I
have to tell you
if I was in legitimate trouble
I would mortgage my house I would take
out loans I would do everything I could
to get rusty Hardin to take my case
that guy gets people off I mean people
dead I mean dead to rights he gets
people up dick Gagarin got Tom DeLay off
and they had pictures of Tom delayed
handing out checks on the floor of the
Congress and Dick Gagarin got him off
but those guys won't come within a
country mile of somebody like Donald
Trump because Donald Trump they end up
having you know what a Mr Green
situation is
never heard of that a Mr Green situation
I saw it in a movie once too and I was
like that's not real that's a Lincoln
lawyers with uh McConaughey yeah I was
like that's not real and I was talking
you know I've got a lot of friends that
are special agents got a lot of friends
that are lawyers got friends I'm like
that's not real and they're like oh yes
it is oh yes it is what they do is you
got a client that's got means to pay and
you tell the judge hey uh we need a
continuance because one of my Witnesses
is hard to find which witness Mr Green
and that judge is like oh okay yeah
we'll we'll take a two-week continuance
so you can find Mr Green and that tells
your client
pay your damn bill or I'm about to walk
right and the judge is okay with it you
know what I mean
guys that people that get around Trump
are just constantly facing this
situation they put in thousands of
man-hours into his [__] and then
when the check's supposed to show up
it never does right or it's a partial or
it's you know some excuse or well you
got a lot of exposure off of this well I
got news for you man
exposure don't buy no Subway sandwiches
it just doesn't you know
I mean I can tell you one person who
isn't afraid of trump or any of his
lawyers and that would be Jack Smith and
so he was seen just this morning on in
DC again no one no one and I said at the
beginning of the show like no one's been
able to track this guy down and where he
is like the guy is in some safe house
working with the team somewhere because
whenever as anyone has seen a photo it's
just been him in his older positions of
like when he before he had a beard or
when he was sitting uh hearing before uh
a case right
um
and there's only two points it's
straight on and from the side and that's
it and no one has spotted this guy
outside of those moments and so now
MSNBC has actually caught him on the
street and they actually tried to talk
to him C news just got exclusive video
of special counsel Jack Smith who was
overseeing the classified documents
investigation let's listen in
foreign
back from NBC news here
it's an indictment coming soon sir
yes we're wrapping up sir
dude he's busted out smiling he is
smiling so hard right there he's trying
so hard not to smile NBC News just got
it yeah it's it's hilarious oh look who
we have the man himself look oh look a
little Rosie there Tony I got some sun
yesterday oh wow I figured I'd pop in uh
for my my vacation in my pool here yeah
oh and you're in your pool yeah I'm
still in my pool Gear with my son is
that the same is that the same were you
at Mar-A-Lago yes I was helping drain
the Mar-A-Lago pulley oh that makes a
lot of sense the secret mission I was on
flooding the sir the other server room
this time right right yeah so there it's
a different crime uh no I guess it's
like when I leave and I go to my bunker
the George Soros bunker you happen to be
gone off you were off site doing a
little bit of a mission right exactly
did he pay you did he actually pay you
well I mean that's um I can't disclose
this kind of things on the show all
right
now I want to say I want to say about
this and the reason why I chimed in here
because I've been I've been watching in
the background this morning and you're
doing a fantastic job as the host oh
thank you you really aren't and and the
audience loves you all the comments were
coming in yesterday I was watching them
and you know it says you're no Tony
Michaels but you are [__] Tony
Michaels so anyway I get a bone to pick
with you earlier I was listening and you
said the f word and then apologized word
I don't know what the [__] you're
apologizing for here on our show for
saying yeah I saw it text Paul goes [__]
I was like what on the jack on the jack
smith thing let me tell you about the
cold calculated silence that Jack Smith
just struck the fear in the heart of
Donald Trump because now now this guy
now this guy uh is public it's shown
he's on the street he's a real person
he's walking around and and you damn
well better bet grandpa is going to
respond to this uh later on today or
probably tomorrow and he's just [__]
[__] in his diapers over this
especially over Jack Smith not saying a
goddamn word and it just shows you it
just shows you the not not only that
that Grandpa poopy pants is in big
trouble here but he can't get a single
an even a no comment he can't even he
can't even wrench out a no comment from
Jack Smith so I think that's that's what
I think I mean this this video came out
uh about an hour and 20 minutes ago and
the closest thing that we have from
Trump is two hours ago when he got the
news about the live golf and the PGA
merging right and then he posted a
couple videos about Patriots of D-Day
addressing the rise of chronic childhood
illnesses god the guy cares about kids I
[__] doubt that he care he does not
care about his own kids okay and this
guy's over here trying to post about how
he cares about other kids but no I
haven't seen anything yet on the uh on
Truth social about Donald Trump reacting
yet to Jack Smith but again like the
idea that you know because
if you look at the the opposite reaction
right Donald Trump would wholeheartedly
stop every person
that is a republican for sure but
definitely Donald Trump would stop in
their tracks and be like oh yeah again
and then give a whole [__] 45-minute
speech right
unrelated nonsensical uh uh no no idea
of what he's saying and then he would
reveal uh some other crime that he did
right he would admit to something that
he had done previously and so
the idea that Jack Smith it's like if
TMZ went up to a celebrity was like hey
can we get a you know give me a little
photo into like a signature and and you
know but Jack Smith [__] laser
[__] laser he's going he's going to
I'm assuming he was going to the to the
the doj but again no one has seen Jack
Smith outside
I think this might be the first sighting
that we've had of Jack Smith since
he left
his previous position came back to the
U.S
and then doesn't it look like because
I've said before that he eats nails for
breakfast yeah doesn't it look like the
dude eats
like frozen food like he didn't cook it
he just eats it right out of the package
well he I just like oh frozen pizza I'm
gonna eat this Jack Smith seems kind of
like the guy where
he would tell you it's not worth his
time he would eat the frozen food and be
like why would I waste my time doing
that right it doesn't make sense right I
can do way more things I can just get
the nutrients he's like look I could be
way more efficient if I put it in my
mouth and and cook it that way right
like the [__] furnace of Jack Smith
Heats it up in his mouth he's like look
by the time it gets to my stomach it'll
be finished cook it'll be done don't
worry about it I can focus he's like I'm
focused on other things right now I can
multitask I can triple task right right
you know it's the but the idea that uh
that he gave no answer that he didn't
even respond he did not even look he
never gave a side eye he never turned
his head he never like
smiled smirked nothing
just blinders on and he was like this
he's like this ain't my first rodeo guys
man I [__] was at the Hague I've done
this [__] on an international level I
don't need you guys you know asking me
questions because I'm dealing with this
[__] orange jump a lump right
I've been totally avoiding this uh
indictment prediction thing on this
because you really can't tell I mean you
can't tell from the outside for the most
part you can't tell and then this news
broke yesterday that the Trump lawyers
were at the doj and I didn't think crap
about that because for folks that Don't
Know Jack Smith the reason you see him
walking into the doj in mid-afternoon
his offices are not in the Department of
Justice yeah when they hired him they
bought him his own office
he works out of a non-disclosed location
with his staff I mean there's probably a
hundred people that work for him in an
office building indeed you know probably
Virginia or DC somewhere or you don't
know where it is and and it for his
lawyers Trump lawyers to be going to the
doj is freaking meaningless it's just
meaningless
except I found out this morning that
Jack Smith had actually taken a little
secret trip and and that's the other
thing you don't have to be seen going
into the doj he wanted to make that
March he did he parked publicly he he
has the same access that the director
and everybody else does there's a reason
you don't you don't see Merrick Garland
walking with his lunchbox into work you
know he doesn't you don't have to be
seen he wanted to be seen there when I
found out that he had actually taken a
trip in to actually sit with Trump's
lawyers
I called my friend back you know I
talked to him about it and a special
agent friend and he was the same as me
he's like yeah that's that's nothing
that's they're giving him the courtesy
of making their last please and and and
and and and asks and it's just a
courtesy so that they can say that they
didn't shut him out
but when I found out Jack Smith was
there
and made the trip down there and then on
top of that his his grand jury
reconvenes this week I was okay that's
it that's it Jack Smith is the lawnmower
and Grandpa poopy pants as Tony says is
the is the freaking great his ass is
grass I'm telling you it's it's that
simple it is that simple this is a done
deal I guarantee you before Friday
we will be talking about Grandpa poopy
pants is indicted on this documents case
I I am going to stick my neck out there
and I'm going to say you think by Friday
by Friday oh yeah I think you're I think
I I mean I'm gonna go out on lemons I'm
gonna say I don't think that's gonna
happen I actually think it's gonna take
a lot longer than that I mean in any
normal indictment yeah maybe by Friday
but I mean we're talking about Donald
Trump and there's no telling how many
rocks Jack Smith has to uncover here now
I will say that it is likely within the
next few weeks we will have a sealed
indictment that maybe the American
public won't know about uh I mean that's
possible but I I think it's going to be
much longer than that and it's just my
opinion though like just looking at it
from a perspective of 50 000 foot level
and and it's going to piss people off
right like the country's ready for this
guy to be indicted and not just like
they're excited about it like even even
Ted Cruz I think was on Fox news this
morning saying yeah they're going to
indict this [__] because Merrick
Garland is pissed off he's not a Supreme
Court Justice as if that had anything to
do with Donald Trump right I think from
last night well [__] me I I was a little
you know okay
conspiracy theories in the Channel A lot
of people are saying I'm hungover or I'm
[__] high that's where I'm wearing
these glasses but then everyone knows
that I don't hide my eyes if I'm
hungover or stoned that's all Bs I and I
didn't have lasers or eye surgery either
I had perfect vision just like I'm
perfect and everything else my vision is
perfect just ask my wife okay this is
how we're clear people get it Tony the
clearer people get it we understand what
you're going through
no no I I mean I'll take my glass I'm
not hungover I wish I said you were
still I was like Tony might still be
missing last uh last ping that we got
are you calling me fat man no man I'm
saying I've I've been there dude the
eyes are swollen even your nose is
swollen bro oh yeah you really got some
sun but I needed it I needed some sun
here's here's what we did um and then
and then I'm gonna let you guys take
take the show back over because
I think I'm gonna go um maybe do some
other [__] that I want to do but here's
the thing because yesterday we went down
the Lake of the Ozarks as people know
I'm from there and I don't live too far
from there um uh anymore I'm about an
hour from there but here's the thing is
that that's where the Netflix series
Ozark was but we went down and we were
we were Lakeside we were poolside we
didn't get a boat yesterday we're
probably gonna get a boat next time but
we sat in the pool and I was in the pool
all day we ate food and I may or may not
have drank Margaritas I don't know
it's possible that's what happened we'll
see
um if there's ever report on this but
but I had a lot of fun and I want to
tell Gabe thank you and I appreciate you
doing the show yesterday you did a great
job and I'm I'm so glad that Rachel
joined yesterday in Texas Paul I'm
thankful that you came on today again
it's Tuesday so why not and help Gabe
out so and I thank the audience for
hanging in there yeah and I know um
there's one comment here that says
Tony you're cute but not as cute as Gabe
so I see I see exactly how it goes and
how it is so I'm gonna get the hell out
of here yeah I'll say the first time I
ran the show myself and I was you know
yesterday I was like you know still
because here's the thing that people
don't know is we're running like while
we're talking we're we are the ones that
are pulling up clips and we're
responding to comments and pulling those
up at the same time so doing it at the
same time is a bit of a learning curve
uh when you've got also another pitch
isn't it yeah yeah it's a lot of work
man it takes I mean I've been doing this
for what is this how many episodes is
this 400 this is 411. so not counting
yesterday I've done it 409 times so it
is a [__] and it takes some
practice yeah you did a great job
yesterday they did a great job today I
listened to your a block today as you uh
went on and it was difficult for me not
to come into the broadcast today I'll
admit I I told myself I wouldn't but I
just couldn't help myself so uh Texas
Paul thanks for being here Gabe thanks
for doing the show give them give them
all your love and I'll continue to watch
oh I may I'm not gonna pop in [__]
I'm going back on vacation all right
yeah take it take a break we'll see
we'll see him tomorrow all right uh so
you know yeah what I was saying there
though Gabe um to go to go back onto
that I talked to a special agent for
friend of mine then we had breakfast
today and from yesterday to today he had
the same exact assessment because I
don't know if you know this but if
you're the subject you know you're the
subject of an investigation okay if you
do right
you're the last person they talk to
they literally talked to everyone else
before they talk to you and the fact
that Jack Smith was there and from what
I understand several of his key
prosecutors were there this was that
meeting this was the last I am touching
base with you I'm going to ask you a
couple key questions and then I'm going
to indict your ass that's what that
meeting was about and I let me tell you
Public Service Announcement folks if you
ever sit down with the FBI
and or really any special agent Federal
special agent because they're all
trained extremely well if you have to
sit down with one and you know you might
be the subject of an investigation
you say exactly these words
oh I made that telling you that's it
that's all you do do not send your
lawyers to the doj to talk these guys
are idiots right idiots we were laughing
about that so hard this morning because
these cocky bastards thought that they
were gonna walk in and they were gonna
sling some oh my God the agents that are
working on this are laughing there
passes off this morning and then you see
Jack Smith you can see him man he is so
hard trying to fight that smile back I
mean he they are yeah he's he he knows
like he knows obviously he he knows
everything right despite the fact of
whether Trump you know is aware of what
he knows or aware of what he did right
it's it's one of those things where Jack
Smith is like man I know all the [__]
plays you're gonna come with like I have
all the cards I know exactly what you
did what you said this and that I mean I
saw I saw a tweet I don't know if I can
I'll try to find it but there was a
tweet that somebody had between
lawyer one uh with Jack Smith lawyer two
with Jack Smith and lawyer three with
Jack Smith and basically they were like
hey so
with any chance that we can like not do
this and they're like nope and then the
lawyer two is like hey you know can we
get around like for example and then the
lawyer three was like Hey so I can flip
on both of these guys if you need me to
right now so the idea that even those
Within
his own legal team you know it just is a
joke but also probably wouldn't be
surprising to see one of them flip and
snitch on the other ones to be like
actually Trump told me a lot of stuff
and I don't know if you know this or not
but [__] man there are more crimes that
you you probably want to look into right
and I'm sure Jackson is like no I know I
know
and it it the the Trump team leaked this
I I guarantee you the doj is not leaking
any of this it none of this is coming
out of the doj it's all coming out of
the Trump team that they offered a a
deal for him to plead guilty
with no jail time
yeah and Jack Smith went
nope not gonna happen
yeah but yeah and I guarantee yeah the
the idea that they would even go in
there I guess they're like ah [__] we
have no plays left like we have nothing
left to actually bring forward and be
like could we negotiate this something
you know like and it's like God and he's
like he's like why the [__] would I give
you the time of day to even to even put
that in the realm of possibility there
is no chance you know what he did he
knows what he did though he probably
thinks that he didn't do it or it wasn't
wrong obviously but I know what I what
he did and I have everything to prove it
right and I'm about to show that [__] to
this grand jury
and have them you know say like yeah we
should indict right
and and the worst part about this is
this is something that was told to me
that I am no legal Guru I am not was
told me this morning
the case that they're building against
him
this is not
like did you see him go into the bank
and did you see no this is these
documents
were here
right they lied about having these
documents this employee says he saw them
with these documents period and and
that's the case that's it this is not
complicated for juries to understand and
the law surrounding this case isn't
complicated you were stripped of your
clearance on this date
period you had these documents on this
date over here
why why did you have those documents you
were briefed you were told you were
asked to return them why did you have
them over here no good answer bye see
you later send it to this jury we're
done I mean this is and and it gets
worse do you I don't know if you wanted
to talk about this at all but have you
seen what finally Willis has been doing
down in Georgia I I do if yeah please go
on tell us she enjoined DC she's
enjoying Virginia she's enjoying I mean
she has brought in four more
jurisdictions into her case yeah and and
Donald Trump is absolutely screwed there
because if they're at that point that
means she's she's done with her case she
has everything she has talked to other
jurisdictions that have similar cases
right and they have already proven up
their case and they said okay let's do
this together and enjoying them their
case so she's at indictment time too
yeah I mean there's literally left
nothing but coordinating with other Pro
that's it yeah that's it so scary I feel
like there's like a cheerleader Squad
being like Rico re-go read like the idea
that that she is doing that right that
she's pulling all of these other
jurisdictions that have similar crimes
of marriage be like they're all
connected through this conspiracy of a
network of planning to overturn the
election via these actions right
is
I mean like unsurprising that Trump
would do this right but also like they
weren't even things that I had in my
realm of knowledge of that were going on
and the fact that she's like all right
great I already teamed up and we're
going to collaborate and now we've got
this crazy Synergy of a RICO case to
come against Trump because at first it
was like oh yeah we've got New York
right we've got Manhattan
aging Carroll uh we've got uh Fulton
County and then we've got two in in
Florida right but now Fulton County is
now expanded beyond that it's actually
like the scope is much larger so you
know I mean to Tony Tony actually
mentioned this and I'll play the clip
um this is Ted Cruz
playing victim about how mayor Garland
is personally trying to attack
uh
Donald Trump the hypocrisy is massive
and mark my words I believe Merrick
Garland will indict Donald Trump
Donald Trump because he hates Donald
Trump he hates him he's angry Merrick
Garland is angry that he wasn't
confirmed to the Supreme Court he wants
to indict him the hypocrisy is massive
you know but it's it's it's funny he
brings up you know that Merrick Garland
was uh
was
upset that he didn't get the Supreme
Court nominee it's like I wonder I
wonder who might have been involved in
that right it seems like there would
have been some sort of like Senate
confirmation right and Ted Cruz might
have been one of those people and I'm
not saying that mayor Garland has that
kind of like chip on his shoulder
but when you know he gets nominated
and then they're like oh no no no it's
too close to the election and Mitch
McConnell and everyone else is trying to
say that no Obama won't get another
Supreme Court nominee and then of course
when Donald Trump is in there they're
[__] ramming them through and you've
got
um Amy Coney Barrett who's done you know
in in less than a month right people
have already submitted their their
mail-in ballots right
um
and so I I find that argument funny you
know I'm not saying like I'm not saying
that Merrick Garland is or does have
that chip on his shoulder but like of
all people again you know unsurprising
it's Ted Cruz who wants to play victim
this is the same guy who just I don't
know a week ago was on Newsmax
complaining about this new uh the the
new uh primary you know uh rival against
him from the Democratic party where he's
like guys I need you to go to
tedcruz.com go to tedcruz.com go to
tedcruz.com I need you to donate like
these people are freaking out whether
it's through illegal
issue or it's because their own position
of power as a senator representative
whatever is at stake because the people
who are their constituents are fed up
right
um you just you just sent me a link here
uh is there you know I'll pull it up
um
this is the Georgia probe of trump
rawness to activities in other states so
this is what you're talking about Fannie
Willis yeah just Clifton us on that what
what they're looking at is you know they
they provided these fake slates of
electors that was part that is part of
the crime and where we Rico comes in is
that you have all you had all of these
states coordinate to do this
so this is one of the predicates that
they had to reach
you know for to for a RICO indictment
and it's just plain and simple and
you've got the DC prosecutor looking at
this that has all of them where they
mailed in these fake slates of electors
and then some of these electors even
showed up I mean they they are going
back to each individual state that did
this and working with their prosecutors
and and this is not going to be just a
Donald Trump case this is going to gut
the Republican party right because I
mean you can't run from Rico guys you
just can't if you don't know
I've you know it does you don't have to
pull the trigger in a RICO case right
right you know if you're just a dumbass
that sent out the memos in the
Republican party in freaking Arizona
that said we don't think Donald Trump
lost we're going to put this alternative
slate of electors together
and you're the guy that just coordinated
that chip
well your ass is fried just as much as
Donald Trump says right I mean you are
going for whatever the longest Haul is
you just took that right
and I guarantee you like you were
talking about people flipping okay like
like you were talking about people
absolutely people are those big
yeah
no sorry go on no you were absolutely
right when those big charges start
dropping and they realized that Uncle
Rico is coming to visit
they are going to flip like you won't
believe they are going to be they and
it's not going to be the guys you know
the the super patriotic oh I'll die for
Trump guy no he's got to go home to his
wife you know he's got to go home to his
wife and she's gonna deal with the hell
you're not but hell you're not you're
gonna make the best deal you can and
you're going to be here and earn a
living for your kids exactly and it's
that simple I mean yeah I mean Nadine
Lopez says Rico Suave I mean I see some
other people Uncle Rico I see uh I saw
Puerto Rico in here as well I mean it it
you know to and I'll let me just pull up
this uh this article it's from The
Washington Post
um the one that Texas Paul sent me and
in here you know they say in Atlanta
area investigation of alleged election
interference by President Donald Trump
and his Alice have brought in to include
activities in DC in several of the
states according to two people with
knowledge uh it all says along the way
you know she has signaled publicly that
she may use George's racketeer influence
and corrupt organizations RICO statute
to alleged efforts yep Uncle Rico right
there allege that these efforts amounted
to a far-reaching criminal scheme
because I mean it's not I mean it's not
surprising right like if you're going to
try it in one state you're gonna try it
in other states as well you're not going
to be like oh well it's I need all I
need is Georgia guys Georgia is the one
state that I tried this because he's
probably all also thinking at the same
time
I either need a contingency plan you
know like if Georgia doesn't pull
through I need this other state that's
going to get me to the 270 right I need
uh or I need this other state to follow
through with electors or whatever it
might be and so you had you have to
admit and it makes sense right you have
to imagine that it's not just Georgia
but he's reaching out to other states
and be like look I need you to flip and
turn around despite what the outcome of
your voters indicated on the ballot I
need you to say that actually we found
these other ballots and these other
votes that nobody knew about and despite
that like we're going to actually have
these these fake electors go forward
right even on Jan six like these people
were trying to give this [__] to Mike
Pence and be like hey we got this fake
electors and this was the one one moment
where Mike Pence was like I'm not gonna
play that game
uh uh but and yeah and you and you've
seen it too you had to follow social
media as part of your job just as much
as I do and you've seen that Lindsey
Graham has been in the [__] for the
last week I mean he they've been
attacking him why because Uncle Rico
went to South Carolina
and all of a sudden Lindsey Graham you
know I mean he may you know be Lindsay
and do Lindsay things but he he kind of
likes to do it on Lindsay's term I mean
he was also he was also the same the
same guy who tried to fight this
investigation and be like no no no you
can't I'm I you I you can't interview me
you can't because I'm I'm not irrelevant
I'm gonna use this protection you know I
think was it it was the same it was the
same protection that Mike Pence tried to
argue against uh Jack Smith right which
was like his position I forget the
actual term I don't know if you remember
but he tried to use that precedence okay
privilege right executive privilege and
and tried to say like oh actually I'm
protected under this and they're like no
the [__] you weren't you are not
protected under this all you you don't
have this position it doesn't fall under
you and also like this is irrelevant to
what was happening remember you were
making phone calls to be like hey
Georgia
can you guys help
toss out these legal mail-in ballots
right
he went to Georgia
he went to Georgia and tried to make
that happen I mean Lindsey Graham's ass
is in a crack man I mean he is
he he better be singing like a freaking
Italian tenor that's all I've got to say
is he he better be singing his ass off
because if he's not
Uncle Rico's got you baby
yesterday there was this there was this
moment that was a ton of Shifting Gears
there's a moment yesterday from
um it was between uh Korean Janine Gene
Pierre uh this is the White House
secretary and it was it was this
it was Republicans getting upset about
how you know she quoted she quoted
because it had to do with Biden right
and they were questioning Biden's
legitimacy and and this was the
interaction that she had and it was it
was well executed
he really had one had one of the best uh
midterm outcome for a new Democratic
president in 60 years in 60 years and so
look um I'll leave you with a quote here
here's something uh that I think that
was said a couple days ago it's a
Huffington Post headline after calling
Joe Biden senile Republicans complain he
outsmarted them I'll leave it there okay
the
I mean it's it's two it's too I mean
like again like you're looking at you're
looking at Donald Trump a guy who is on
uh well who is in invested under
investigations it has been in court has
to go back to court in next march will
probably go you know this year as well
in terms of arraignment under these
pending potential indictment charges
right uh the Republican party is like
yeah that's the guy that's the guy we
want to do the guy who literally is is
like seething sees red at all
possibilities and post on true social
and all caps about how D.A Alvin Bragg
is is coming after him unjustly it's all
fake news is a Witch Hunt this and this
and that
and the Republicans want to go after Joe
Biden because they're like oh like he
tripped on stage okay well he got right
back up and he [__] joked about it
people were at the white house yesterday
and they're like he he gave his speech
right and then he he interacted with
people on a one-on-one level for an hour
and so then you have this moment where
Republicans are like oh well Joe Biden's
age is a thing that we should worry
about
well if that's something we should worry
about you know it's the same people who
are like well he's sleepy Joe Biden he
was in a basement he was on a recliner
he wasn't doing anything and at the same
time he's like he outmaneuvered
outsmarted and outwitted every
Republican and Kevin McCarthy put them
in a box and said look you're gonna do
what I want you're not going to make the
cuts that you want and you're gonna have
to say yes sir thank you sir and that's
what he did right and that's that's what
happened and that's another example like
well what is he is he this Grand
Puppeteer Overlord
or is he the senile incompetent man like
well you you can't have it both ways
um and it's just it's just another
beautiful moment and there's going to be
many more but Republicans are going to
have a hard time trying to argue of the
accomplishments right like yeah I mean
you know
that's that that's like you know me
getting into the ring with Mike Tyson
and saying you're an old [__] man yeah
what the hell are you doing then taking
a solid ass whooping and then I mean
which is it is he old and useless or did
he just whip my ass I mean let's go to
the tape Johnny right exactly like let's
review the tape you you know I was
talking with uh Dr Rachel bidikoff for
yesterday and it's it's one of those
things but it's like during the state of
the union he called out Republicans and
he was like look Republicans want to cut
Medicare and Social Security and they're
like
no we don't know we don't no we don't no
we don't like you know Margie Taylor
Green's like liar and he's like okay
great you guys now are on the record you
guys have stated for Millions to watch
and see that you are against this rumor
that you want to make these cuts
and then leading up to this whole thing
everyone's like so you know it sounds
like they're making the cuts sounds
making cuts and Joe Biden's like look
man I haven't seen anything official
it's all been hearsay
hey unless you like there was the
interaction they had with the reporter
he's like unless Kevin McCarthy gave you
their planned budget I haven't seen [__]
but I know you want to cut it I love
that interview it was the same interview
where he got all salty and he's and he's
like this is why you guys can't
negotiate for [__] I was like wow
you got to put the sunglasses on and
warn me that the dark branding is coming
man
he'll come out a little bit one moment
and then be like
like he'll just whisper into the mic and
then and then come back and really be
like look here comes dark Brandon
it's it's some it's amazing to watch an
amazing and watch them freak out and for
folks in the audience I am that is not
hyperbole I mean he really got up in the
mic and said yeah that's why you people
can't negotiate that's why I am really
good at this bye
see ya and walked off you know it's it
it is it is always always funny to watch
these Republicans I know we say it on
the show like they they constantly are
walking on rakes right it's the sideshow
Bob moment from Simpsons where they take
one step they hit a rake and like and
then they turn over and they hit a
regular and they and they're like okay
well I instead of avoiding these rakes
here and I notice that there's rakes
over there they go now let me go into
another rake and you're like how dumb
are you right it's these The Narrative
talking points you know uh Harris
Faulkner on Fox News is another one the
idea that she's like I was kicked out of
a restaurant for openly bowing my hand
my head in prayer hands right and you
look you look at you know I'll play this
clip right now
but like please yeah you look at this
and you're like uh that never happened
you guys continue to play the victim
right Alex I would like to take [__]
that never happened for a thousand
please exactly like the idea that you're
like oh this happened and you're like
sounds like Margie Taylor green sounds
like Lauren bobert it sounds like every
other person from the Republican Party
who says something happened and they
were the victim and then you're like
with either just simple you know kind of
common sense or even talking to someone
at this place that they said this thing
happened they'd be like uh nope we don't
nope they never even came in that day
but we don't have any record of that
person ever existing or coming through
that that region right
the ZIP code
FYI every restaurant with any kind of
money like that this woman would go to
they all have cameras that look over
your booth they all do so if something
you say something happened the manager
says I'm so sorry let me take care of
that for you and he walks back in his
office he sits down he goes to your
booth he backs the tape up and watches
did it oh yeah it did happen didn't it
okay let me go fix this if it didn't
happen he comes back out and he that's
good escorts your ass out of the
restaurant and tells you don't come back
that's why she doesn't name anyone here
right that's why she doesn't give any
details exactly and this is so this is
what she had to say in this 35 seconds
we know who we are and we know whose we
are
for those of us who believe we must be
bold in our faith right now
when you gather in public spaces pray
thankfully over your food even when the
server gives you the stink eye or tells
the manager that your peaceful Grace is
triggering them
had it happen to me no I've been asked
to leave a restaurant for openly bowing
my head in prayer hands
in America
it's all good they don't deserve my
money anyway
we know it's it's all good it we we know
exactly who we are like what the [__] is
she talking this never happened this
actually reminds me
exactly of Margie Taylor green when she
said that she went to a restaurant with
her with her AIDS and she said that a
person came up and harassed them
and then the next day she was on a
Committee hearing and she retold this
story and again it's like Alex I'll take
a thousand for things that never
happened
because it never happened right they
play victim they say oh no no look look
I had like any person also
I can't imagine
that anyone
who put their you know prayer hands are
like this or however she forms her hands
in in bows her head I mean depending on
where she is assuming that she never
left the New York area
the diverse amount of people
of religious backgrounds who pray right
whether they're Muslim or Jewish or
Christian or catholic whatever it might
be
every one of those people
I guarantee pray at different times of
the day in public right
and no one's like oh you can't do that
here
not at all not at all it's again
something that never happened and but
she's like oh it's all good they don't
need my business it's like probably
because you were never there to begin
with
you know I was I was at a pride event
this weekend
and you had some church folks show up at
the edge there
none of them were there out of love
none of them they were as hateful as can
be so they got they got I'll be honest
with you they got really hateful retorts
I mean people were just rude as could be
to these church people because they were
there and they were spouting hateful
crap and the most hateful vitriol went
towards there was a an old couple there
and you know me Gabe
you do you with your religion man I'll
take a bullet for you to do for you to
do you with your religion just get it
the hell out of my government you know
right that just keep your damn pedophile
leading churches out of my government
out of my schools out you know but you
do you man so these people want to be
there
great but they went after this older
couple that their Church emblem has a
rainbow underneath it because they're
inclusive They Don't Preach hate at
their Church those were the people that
absolutely triggered them the most
and the vitriol and every and it's just
like this garbage
she may have bowed her head and prayed
at that restaurant she may have
but that ain't what got her kicked out I
guarantee you she was shitty she was
nasty she was like most people there's
nothing there is no hate like Christian
love man I'm telling you
that is what got her kicked out I
guarantee if she ever got kicked out
which I you know I highly doubt that but
if she did get kicked out it was because
she [__] all over her server right you
know I mean it it had nothing to do with
the fact that she prayed or anything
like that oh yeah yeah you know I could
see her trying to trying to Danger proof
herself because she had a rude exchange
at a restaurant that she knows
eventually is going to come out so she's
trying to pre-frame it as I just prayed
and they threw me out no you didn't you
shot it's just [__] all over your server
right you know because you're you're IST
ma'am we're making some more iced tea I
want to bring you a glass of fresh what
the hell is wrong with you you know do
you know who I am I saw you bring them
iced tea why didn't you bring it to me
you know I mean [__] like that you can
just see it's freaking privilege all
over this camera I mean yeah and and not
only that but like you look at it and
you're like this is the argument that
they try to make like we need safe
spaces for republicans
um is it that you need safe spaces or
it's that you want to create a hostile
vile environment where you can say
whatever you want do whatever you want
to other people because they're
different they don't have the same
beliefs or ideologies or because you
feel so insecure and Petty about
yourself because you can't be like them
and you're part of this Republican party
that has to be straight white CIS uh
Christian you know all like whatever it
might be you have to be this one mindset
that you can't feel comfortable to be
yourself and it's unfortunate that those
people have to feel that way and they
only feel that way that they feel
comfortable is to hate on other people
and hold them down right and so you look
at
what Faulkner is saying here
and it's like yeah I guarantee if we if
she did in fact go somewhere I guarantee
somebody pulls the tape and goes this
was the interaction right this I mean
these are the same people that say hey
hey get that [__] Pride [__] out of
my store God damn it don't raise that
flag up here because these people don't
exist but then also the very same people
are like we're loving Christians and you
know what you're we're gonna make sure
that there's a [__] King James Bible
and every goddamn motel in America right
so when they come after people and
they're like oh they're grooming and
they're forcing this on us and it's like
is it that or is it the fact that your
grooming and you're forcing yourselves
on other people and they're just not
having it right so when Faulkner's like
I prayed my hands it's like maybe you
probably did other things and the people
weren't having it and you got upset that
you couldn't have your say right
yeah and I tell you and there was one
incident in a pride march here last year
that I I'm not exactly sure how I feel
about this game and this is what I want
to run run by yeah yeah but I under on
one hand I understand it and on the
other end of it
you know because I've always been like
like these people showed up at this
Pride event
why why are you here we're not coming to
your church
and interfering with your church
services why are you coming to this
Pride event to interfere with this but
last year in a March the March went by a
church in Thailand it's in downtown
Tyler and people got really loud and
really you know I mean they really
started to throw it out there as we
passed this church
and you're starting to see more and more
Pride events where they're not just
waiting for these obnoxious people to
come to them they're going to them
they're they're protesting at their
churches and stuff it's very rare but
it's happening now and I'm not exactly
sure how I feel about it
because
you know I mean everybody has the right
I may think that your church is a
pedophile-laden piece of crap right but
you have your right to your religion as
long as I don't find out you're diddling
kids in there you know what I mean
you've got the right to your religion
but on the other end of it you know what
you take your [__] and you put it in my
schools you take your [__] you put it in
you know we're out here having it was is
it Square everybody was keeping to
themselves it was just a pride rally
they had a pride March and then then a
rally in downtown Tyler and these people
showed up and they were not there
to spread love they were not there to
try to help people that they think have
gone astray or anything they were
hateful little bastards you know yeah so
I don't know exactly sure how I feel
about it on one hand of me one hand I
actually like it take that [__] to them
give them a taste of it protest outside
their their churches and [__] like that
but then on the other hand I'm like you
know what
I don't know I don't know that I
absolutely agree with that I don't know
where you come in on that game but it's
starting to throw that out there no no
not at all I mean I guess like you know
obviously
you know you wanna you wanna be in a
situate or I don't know it's like it
would be great to live in a society
where people didn't hate each other
right or that people practiced the very
thing that they preached right and you
see a lot of that from the religious
community whether it's through misogyny
sexism uh racism bigotry whatever and
then try to scapegoat and say oh you
know what that's uh you know actually uh
those are all fine because my religion
says so or you know I'm not this or
whatever right
um
and there's a party I was like yeah you
know like [__] dish it back but I
don't know I think there is a there is a
a limit there is a bar to which you can
say
okay that's enough right
um but you I don't know I mean like you
look at all the things that are done by
people from the religious community and
it's you know the very reason why you
know I went to Catholic grade school and
I studied Christianity for a period of
time thinking like oh maybe I should do
this in high school and then I got to a
point where I was like you know what all
religion is [__] right it's terrible but
that's my own personal opinion and I'm
not gonna force that on other people
unless of course like you pointed out
unless you guys are doing something
crazy but I can also identify a lot of
problems in society that have been
linked directly to
religious communities right especially
when you're trying to you know Force
indoctrinate whatever
but the way I look at it it's like it's
yeah I don't know I mean like it's it's
a tough one because you would hope that
everyone who do practice those things
would say I practice love and empathy
and I care about my neighbor and I want
to make sure that we do live in a
society that's safe for everyone
regardless of who you are you can
practice what you want and I can
practice what I want and they back there
can practice whatever they want right
but it shouldn't be something where you
get so offended especially if it's
nothing like bad or illegal or anything
like that
but like we should be able
theoretically to
to to live in a society where
you can say and practice what you want
without other people without forcing
other people rather right if people like
it okay right I'll come join your
congregation or I'll join your group or
your community or whatever that should
be enough right I don't have to go on
the street corner and preach it in
somebody's face or yell at them because
they're you know that they're going to
hell because they're not doing this or
the complete opposite right
um
I don't know I think it's you know
that's kind of my thoughts on that
um
I don't know I don't know if other
people in the in the I see a lot of
people in the comments that are saying
you know I don't care what people do
just please don't try to sell your view
onto me completely agree again you know
we should be able to live in a society
where you can do whatever you want you
know
of course legally again uh without
having to worry about other people
forcing or judging or you know coming
after you for that right
uh and that's that's the problem that
that's the big problem and why I you
know I used to never be for ultra high
tax brackets when I I would used to be
mortified that the 70 to 90 percent tax
bracket existed
before I understood before I Grew Older
and before I understood like there's a
guy here in Texas by the name of Ferris
Wilkes he is a billionaire
he is not a blue blood he grew up a
bricklayer I mean he grew up in his
daddy's Seventh-day Adventist Church
Yahweh Church of seven three whatever I
can't remember the title of it but it's
one of those out there
it it's it's of the same vein of the as
the Branch Davidians
you know the David koresh people yes
that's the Seventh-day Adventist they've
got a lot of branches and different
veins they're a different branch of that
Seventh-day Adventist stuff
well this guy got into fracking and him
and his brother became billionaires
there's no training to be a billionaire
there is not so you've got this guy that
grew up in a radical ass church that now
has more money laying around than he
could possibly spend in his lifetime
so he's decided he wants to socially
socially engineer our country
and he's spending his money trying to
pack shove his church up our ass
and to me that's when I lose my [__]
you know I really do if you want to go
to your freaky little church where you
don't let women talk and do your thing
and everybody's voluntary and you're all
adults whatever even if you want to take
your kids to that church
you do that okay as long as you're not
raping kids
I will mind my business
but when you
get a [__] ton of money and then turn
around and want to try to shove your
church into my Texas schools which is
what they're doing right now yep you
know they're trying that church vouchers
[__] when you try to force that onto me
well now you have my attention and you
deserve everything that comes your way
because you put your church and my
government and now [__] you you are my
target
I mean I will call you freaks I will
point out the radicalness of your
beliefs I will have people point and
[__] laugh at you for the absurdity
of your I've got a comedy bit for you
that I did the other day for a guy okay
I would it just you know I picked up the
phone
hey uh hey hey hey hey god
um
is it true that that you had Abraham
prove he loved you
by telling him to kill his kid
no no really I I'm serious about that
man no I'm not joking you you really did
that you you
that's not funny man that is not funny
no I didn't no I know you stopped him I
know you stopped him but you didn't stop
him until he had him on the damn altar
with the damn do you think that affected
the kid you [__]
I mean really you know I want people to
prove their love to me it involves maybe
a [__] or something you telling
people to kill their kids
come on man that's in the book people
that's in the book yeah the Bible
translates to the book
that's in the book it's that really
happened it is one of those it's one of
those things like you you know like
being a person who grew up in Catholic
school and and going to going to church
every uh you know almost twice to three
times a week because it was like Sunday
and then we went a couple times during
the week just for a simple like 30-day
map or a 30 minute mass and so one of
the things
that you realize at a certain point
where like these stories
don't
don't make sense like you know for that
reason or like oh King Solomon wanted to
cut the baby in half what the [__] are
what what are we what are we doing here
guys what like this this is not a life
lesson that is a good one
if we're taking it literally like I get
the thing like oh we'll find out the
real owner of it if they're the ones who
are like oh please don't harm the baby
but also the way in which that you're
like oh no this is this is [__]
intense stuff right you've got like
you've got old Old Testament like
omnipotent God like [__] fear fear uh
fear inducing I'm gonna go to the
extreme I'm an abusive father kind of
God and then he has a kid and he's like
oh no don't you know but also it's like
I'm gonna let my kid die I don't know
there's a lot of stories in there where
where you have to ask yourself like
um is are you getting are you getting a
lesson here because we do know
that there are a lot of people who
interpret religion and you know the
scripture how they want and actually one
of those people is this crazy woman
Rachel ham and her son Ezekiel I believe
uh you got that video yeah yeah and uh
she's talking well I don't think I can
explain it to do it justice so I'm just
going to play the video
today's June 1st so quite obviously the
death angel did not visit the Capitol in
the month of May period it did not uh we
did say we didn't know what year it was
so
we are super frustrated we really really
really were praying that it was going to
be this may right it was like
I mean we really wanted it to be this
may I think you really wanted it to be
this may because our country is in such
a bad situation that it just felt like
the death angel needed to come this may
but he didn't
um I have seen a couple of things that
have made me wonder if he's still coming
soon
as far as on the the you know the Hebrew
calendar is not the same as the the
Gregorian calendar and so it still is
possible that it's within this month
which is still has like a couple weeks
left in the Hebrew month so it's
possible that it's still going to be
coming
in the next couple weeks so anyway we're
praying we're praying that it's still
going to come we're praying that it's
soon we're sad that it didn't already
happen
I did a bid on that one too I was like
Hey God hey yeah there's Paul hey man
you think you could get on with that
Rapture thing because I'm tired of
dealing with these sumbitches no really
if the rapture's a real deal can you you
think you could do that like I mean like
soon you know I mean I mean like let's
get look if if this is the end of the
end of days that we're talking about
like [__] get it over already right
like you know you said Jesus Christ was
going to come back years ago you know we
we talked about
the year 2000 all these things he was
going to come back you know this and
that and we're going to find the signs
we're going to get these clear like
markers as to when these things would
happen
and you're like
[__] man this is like an overdue library
book let's go man like I want it to
happen if we're really going to talk
about it if I could just land it now man
but they these people are so deranged
there's a couple reasons I left religion
and start I have my own religion by the
way I do I do believe there's a God and
I can prove it I don't need you to have
faith
I can prove it scientifically but that's
a whole other discussion for another
show I'm not going to drag people down
the whole religion thing
but I will tell you this if you re the
number one way to make someone not a
Christian is to have them read the Bible
and and my favorite one is the story of
Jesus's resurrection because Gabe when
you went to Catholic school did they not
tell you that God was omnipotent
did they not tell you that he could see
everything
he could foresee everything right
then why did he send his son
to be crucified
if he can see everything there's it's a
big question that nobody wants to answer
well I mean
oh I know I mean they're bigger he gets
back up there right they're like he died
for his sins right I mean can you I mean
I did it I did a
a sketch on this back around I think it
was around Easter a couple years ago and
basically it's a conversation between
Jesus and God
and God's like hey do you figure out or
Jesus like uh he's like hey Father's Day
is coming around the corner
did you figure out what you want me to
do or like to get for you and he's like
I did he goes okay great what do you
want me to get you and God's like I Want
You To Die For Me
and she's like whoa whoa what what what
what what are you talking about he goes
it's fine you die I'll bring you back
three days later people will laugh and
cry and and be enjoyed
don't worry about it and and she's like
uh what the [__] no dude I'm not why
would you kill me why do you have to
kill me and bring me back for people to
learn this
it doesn't make any sense right yeah and
and the people acted in the worst
possible way they didn't get the outcome
they wanted they said hey kill Jesus
when given the choice and he's like well
Jesus died for our sins well technically
he didn't he took a long weekend off
because he was resurrected I mean he
didn't like die die he was resurrected
um
so yeah
it took a long weekend off for you
but if you're omnipotent and you knew
all this could you imagine that
conversation when Jesus got back what
the [__] dad you said they knew they
hammered me to a cross they stuck I hate
crown of thorns on my Thorns dad
they beat me with a whip
and you already knew the answer
what the [__] man you didn't need me to
prove anything and if anything I proved
they were [__] right they could have
chosen me no who did they choose they
choose the other freaking guy
not me it's like you could you could
have stopped him dad you you saw what
they were doing to show you how evil and
bad they were and that I had to it's
like you you it's like you let your own
son do that or like you let them do that
to your own son like the amount of
just disconnect an apathy towards your
one and only son you're like yeah yeah
he's like this is tough to watch anyway
anyone want a beer like the idea that
he's just up there watching it and he's
like look I know what's gonna happen
I've seen it happen it's gonna be
questionably rough for me to watch it
happen in real time and even though
that's happening I I still ah man hands
are tied can't do it what's God up there
saying why they're nailing them to the
Cross she's like you see in Jesus ah
tough it up man you're embarrassing me
down there I mean Jesus I could see God
as a real pull yourself up by your
bootstraps kind of guy we're like you go
in and you ask for a favor and he like
points to his son he's like uh-uh you
know what the sign says do it yourself
don't no handouts for me I'm not giving
you [__] you got to work for this
that's the I feel like God in many ways
is like you're like oh I could see him
as a Republican or he like doesn't care
you know
and you know man my favorite one is that
whole Abraham thing with you know hey
kill your son for me to prove you love
me I mean I just can just imagine God
sitting there he's watching hey Gabriel
Michael come here check this out watch
he's gonna do it man
he's really gonna he's gonna I'm telling
you he's gonna do it 50 shekels 50
shekels he does it watch watch oh
uh just kidding just kidding stop stop
you know I mean and you know Gabriel and
Michael are laughing their ass off
he was really gonna kill his kid
nah man that's not a real religion date
but I can tell you someone I can tell
you someone who uh who I'm just getting
breaking news right now in the last hour
someone who I'm sure is going to play
the I'm doing it for the greater good
you know uh trying to use that argument
is George Santos playing victim because
we're finding out more news about the
recent Bond
stop
it's it sounds like it's leading that
way it says uh federal judge in New York
has agreed to unseal records showing
identities of the people who help
representative George Santos make 500
000 Bonds in this criminal fraud case
but judge keeps record sealed through
Friday to give Santas to appeal in
eastern district of New York magistrate
and Y Shields order says an appeal of
this order must be filed by noon on
Friday uh in court filing yesterday
representative George Santos my client
would rather surrender you know again
like if we you know bring back to the
building side he's like this guy's like
you see you know what's coming like you
know what you did was wrong and you know
who's involved and it's like oh I'm
gonna I'm gonna go to I'm such a martyr
I'm gonna go to jail for you guys to
protect whoever these people are that
they put five hundred thousand dollars
in which again is like maybe it's
connected to Miles guo maybe it's Russia
maybe it's some mob may you know who
knows who it is
um it's the GOP that's what that's my
guess my prediction I'll stick my neck
out there and make the prediction it was
the GOP that threw his bail and they
don't want the narrative out there that
you are donating to the GOP so that you
can make sure that uh Santos gets bailed
out of jail right and I still don't want
their money going for that someone in
the chat asked uh I thought this was
yesterday at five so if you're not
caught up right what's going on is they
had a deadline on Friday they asked for
an extension they got it to Monday at 5
PM yesterday at 5 p.m is when this part
happened in the court filing yesterday
representative George Sanchez defense
attorney wrote my client would rather
surrender to pre-trial detainment than
subject these surators to what they uh
what will inevitably come and the judge
was like well this doesn't make any
sense I don't see why this would be a
thing but I'll take it and and then
today this is the updated uh
um situation
in this in this case
um
I'm trying to see if there's any more
that's James yeah Gabe it's [__]
because if you were arrested you through
whoever threw bail for you
that would be a matter of public record
exactly there's no reason that this
record is being sealed or even slowed up
this whole conversation that we're
having is just such bad precedent it
does right there's no reason I mean the
world doesn't know who who posted that
bill there should be no precedent right
there should be no reason
why someone should have you know and
we're coming back all the way to where
the show began which is George Santos
is covering you know the the fact that
George Santos is willing to cover for
whoever these three people are because
at the beginning of the show I said
they're supposedly
according to Murray his attorney he said
there were three people
one person backed out right before and
two people didn't show up to the
arraignment so then they had to secure
three other people right just last
minute now the question is is that the
truth did they really have to secure
three people last minute or were these
are these three people
you know is it a Harlan Crow Harlan
Hitler kind of situation where
somebody's putting you know back in a
lot of money here
uh who knows right
um now he's he wasn't do he's not due
back in court until June 30th but it
sounds like they're they're pushing
forward this idea that um that now now
he's gone until Friday
to announce or or appeal it which is
the fact that he's able to even do that
is so crazy right because there is there
should be and is no precedent as to
protecting because again like you said
if this was anyone else you me or
whoever
these people would have to be revealed
it's public record and that's why these
uh New York Times Washington Post and
all these other news agencies reached
out and they're like uh this is this is
our right to know
who's funding this guy's freedom because
that's what they're doing they put money
up you know to say like this guy should
be free and and we're putting our name
to it now they didn't want to reveal
their name so that's why it makes it
even more interesting that he's willing
to go to jail
for them you know well here's the here's
the stupid part about that
let's say it is a sugar daddy somewhere
that doesn't want their name drugged
through the mud or associated with with
you know Anthony De volder Santos
it doesn't matter it's been done it's a
matter of public record even if he says
um I want my bond back I'm going to go
ahead and take pre-trial confinement
um will you do that judge if the judge
it doesn't matter it's a matter of court
record it's not anything that that will
hold up to challenge about being a
sealed court record
um there's no legitimate argument you
can make that to say I was willing to
put up bond for somebody security for a
bond for somebody
but I am not willing
to have my name out there that that's
not you know so
folks will good journalists will
continue to file the foil requests when
the foyer presser denied they'll take
that to court
and another judge will overturn this and
we'll know right I mean we're gonna know
all this is is George George Santos
trying to prove his loyalty to keep his
defense money coming in that's it and I
think it was the GOP to be honest with
you I really really do nobody I mean
honestly we're at a point where anything
is possible knowing
how each of those parties that I I
mentioned earlier whether it's it's you
know it's Russia or it's miles guo
connected Steve Bannon someone else like
the idea that it could be anyone of
these people you know or the GOP
honestly totally plausible right you you
look at this and you say
any one of these Bad actors
could be
the people behind
this lack of transparency right and
again the fact that they don't want
their identity involved or revealed
they're like Oh They'll suffer great
distress will they I mean I can't
imagine that someone who's willing to
put five hundred thousand dollars on the
line in the event that George Santos
[__] skips town
is is willing to do that if they didn't
have the financial security
you know in liquidity behind them right
so like I can't imagine those people
would care that much unless their
identity is much more than uh
a distress situation right it's
revealing of some other connection
and I can't and again I I see this as
something that's again it's another
rake moment right he tried to fight it
tried to extend it they tried to argue
this it clearly again even before going
into this the judge was like this
doesn't make any sense like I don't know
why he why you would think this was a
valid argument but look I'll hear you
because legally you're allowed that
opportunity
but it makes no sense right
and so the fact that now I mean I wasn't
sure if if we were going to get an
update today this week or if we have to
wait until the 30th when Santos had to
reappear in court
but it looks like you know
um this is going to be a victory for the
AP New York Times and everyone else who
petitioned under a foia request for the
to get that transparency
um
well no judge wants to be overturned
either and this judge has to know yes
there's no precedent for this there's
just no precedence for
for someone being able to hide their
idea I mean if you're willing to post
the bail you've got to be willing to
stand up and say I posted the bail is
that simple right
it's it's something you know somebody
somebody said here is uh Paul Young
Santos died for your sins he he died for
the sins of the donors is what I would
say not for his constituents but
definitely for the sins of the donors I
mean if anything were true you know
connecting you know kind of bringing a
through line from the beginning to the
end here but it's it's something that
will be I I'm very interested to know
who
these people are right because
you know I wonder even if people in his
own team know right if it's just George
Santos or do people that are close like
to vishbura and other people know about
who this connection is who these people
are or are they like honestly I have no
idea like uh that [__] that I don't even
know right but we'll we'll find out I
imagine it says you know by Friday it
sounds like they have to
I think is what it was saying
um
Yeah by Friday it says uh according to
sorry I just had this up a second ago
yeah Friday it seems like but the idea
again the idea that this guy is willing
to go to jail for these people I don't
know kind of says a lot right and it
kind of says a lot like as to do these
people have [__] on him
maybe I don't know but also like does
their name reveal something you know and
it really could be someone in the GOP
someone high up that's that is that is
Behind These backers
so they have until Friday
again to appeal so I don't know this is
going to be something that's going to be
interesting to watch but you know really
really begs the question of who the [__]
is George Santos and I think possibly
these donors will will give some
insights in that maybe
and the last thought on this was is the
reason I believe it's a GOP it's not
just willy-nilly I got a hunch
um they needed Santos out for these
votes they did yeah they need Kevin
McCarthy did not have them you know they
they you know you had a defection in
this last round where they were saying
well we're going to call for a vote you
know to replace McCarthy I mean he was
he did not have a margin to play with
and that's why I really believe
that he pulled some strings to get
Santos out that's just my take on it
I'm willing to come back and say I was
wrong
yeah well it's all it's all coming back
you know all these people uh and I kind
of wrap this thing up here is like
you've got again Jack Smith coming after
Donald Trump you've got the you know New
York coming after George Santos you've
got also the whole Martha's Vineyard
thing that Florida Governor Ron DeSantis
tried to pull that's coming back now
around to get him and not only that
actually it's my people down in Bear
County
that's actually there's actually one
more video I want to play and as Ron
DeSantis the the outcome the cause of
of Rhonda Santos's immigration Bill and
there's a video where Republicans are
now admitting and this is something I
wanna kind of leave it on is is showing
that this is what's going to happen
and this is these are the effects that
are being seen by these dumb idiotic
Republican policies that are not
progressing let me tell the audience
yeah yeah what's going on they never
recovered from Ian you still have houses
off their foundations you've got houses
nice neighborhoods with tarps over their
roofs I mean you've got the the
Florida is a nightmare for
reconstruction right now because you
know even before DeSantis did this
stupidity I mean the costs of
construction had quadrupled
well now they're they've attacked their
their labor base you know granted I
would want these people to have be here
on legal work permits and do it yada
yada yada but the reality is
we have a lot of immigrants come over
here because they're young strapping men
that want to work
they want to work and they work in the
construction Fields man that's how you
get your roofs done that's how you get
your kitchen remodeled that's how you
get and then they did this what you're
about to show and and Florida already
had a desperate need
to rebuild that they couldn't meet and
then decide the Santa's turned around
and took a big giant crap all over
immigrants and they left they left
it's and it's it really is again you
know you're finding
uh-oh these uh these fascist anti you
know isolationist uh kind of policies
aren't doing
the things that Republicans said they
would do and in terms of benefiting the
constituents right and so Thomas Kennedy
here says got footage from inside this
event they they admit the bill is 100 to
scare immigrants and beg the crowd to
urgently convince your people to not
leave Florida since folks in the
agriculture industry are mad workers are
leaving and so again you know he says
the hypocrisy is so Brazen and
disgusting and here it is
this bill is 100
posed to scare you
[Music]
say
I'm a farmer and the farmers are mad as
hell
we are losing employees they're already
starting to move to Georgia and other
states it's
urgent that you talk to all your people
and and convince them that you have
resources state representatives and
other people that can explain the bill
to you families
[Music]
we have the best we had the best
president
in my in my life for the last 30 years
and I'm still supporting Donald Trump I
love my Governor he's the greatest
Governor he's the greatest governor in
and it just it's you know again you know
I'm just kind of leaving on this is like
it's a rake step every part of the way
right they walk boom they walk boom they
walk boom you know you've got this thing
we wanted to scare these immigrants we
wanted to do this but no no no we didn't
want to affect the agriculture in the
industry that is that that Florida is so
entangled with right and so they think
that if they can do this right and again
it goes to Ron DeSantis thinking that
he's going to be the next president he's
got the great policies he's going to
kill woke and this and that and again
he goes after he goes after Disney kills
2 000 jobs that were coming from
California right
say again one more night with that
Disney Disney was the Cornerstone of the
jobs then there were there were
restaurants there were insurance
companies there were uh you know
apartment complexes there were uh paper
supply companies there were everything
that was going to service those 2 000
jobs also evaporated so it's probably
closer to 20 000 jobs yeah there there's
just that one just I guess you know in
not directly in in the park itself but
also those jobs to support those jobs
right and so I get like the ancillary
ones that are tangentially connected for
sure are impacted because
more people means well there's less
opportunity for the you know the the the
ways in which they're connected to as as
as a labor but like again it's this it's
George Santos it's Ted Cruz it's it's
Donald Trump right you have all of these
people you have these crazy right-wing
religious people these Republicans every
step of the way
rake step rake step rake step and I and
I would be uh
I would I would be I would mess up if I
did not acknowledge the fact that
speaking of rake stepping we do have
merch uh and it's the let them eat rake
shirt
which you can get if you go to
store.thetonymichaels.com again
store.dtonymichaels.com and you can get
yourself let them eat rake shirt with a
nice little
Trump elephant stepping on one of many
rakes uh in succession of course but you
know before we go I just want to say
thank you to everyone who came to the
show today Tony was out he popped in for
a minute I want to say thank you to our
awesome awesome moderators they're there
working in the background helping me
letting me know things about what people
said and links to send me as well and I
want to thank Texas Paul for coming on
the show today it wouldn't be it would
not be a taco Tuesday with Texas Paul
without of course Texas Paul and so uh
you know Texas Paul you got anything
coming up right now I know you got your
own show that you do on Sundays and
Wednesdays now yeah man I'm telling you
Wednesdays is rocking we're gonna have a
show tomorrow it'll be a lead-in at the
end of it I'll throw to you guys
um the Wednesday I was actually
concerned you know when you start out
with a new show boom it came out of the
out of the blocks just on fire man so
nice yeah catch us tomorrow at 10
o'clock we'll be here
all right awesome and again you know for
those of you who are listening uh or
watching on YouTube make sure to
subscribe you know check us out hit that
subscribe button on YouTube if you're on
Twitter make sure to follow us at the
Tony Michaels Tony Michael's pod and
also I am Gabe Sanchez and for those
I've got an up uh for for people who
want to check us out on patreon uh you
can go to the patreon.com the Tony
Michaels you can also check out my
patreon where I release episodes that's
like a a Daily Show kind of thing it's
called what was that and you can find
that at what was that show.com or
patreon.com I am Gabe Sanchez and of
course if you're listening check us out
on all the major platforms Spotify apple
and others uh download the episode and
and of course the last one one of the
last ones is on Facebook check us out at
the Tony Michaels and if you are a prime
custom customer make sure to connect
Amazon Prime with twitch we get a couple
dollars of Jeff Bezos money everything
helps keeps the show running paying for
you know stream yard and other services
and we love you all and thank you all
for giving us the time of your day
and also humoring me for hosting the
show while Tony was missing for a period
of time
um so I want to thank everyone the
moderators the audience and Texas Paul
and uh like always
Surfs Up [__] you've been
listening to the Tony Michaels podcast
in your face commentary of current
events and political news no rules No
Boundaries I think we've made that
perfectly clear we hope you enjoyed the
show and we'll be back soon in the
meantime follow toning on social media
at the Tony Michaels and until next time
raise a fist and repeat after me
[__] em
[Music]
Murphy's meal Barn head ass Beacon
thank you
[Music]